[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo und willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Stefan hi
zusammen unser heutiger Fall wurde
seinerzeit als rosa Riese bekannt das
klingt zwar erstmal niedlich oder witzig
war es aber überhaupt nicht absolut
nicht Mirko das werden wir heute
schmerzhaft unter Beweis stellen da traf
es der Begriff von der Bestie von
Beelitz schon er wir zeichnen heute
einen Serienmord im Großraum Berlin nach
der drei Jahre lang die Schlagzeilen
bestimmte
unsere Geschichte beginnt im Wendejahr
1989 im April ist noch nicht absehbar
wie radikal sich alles ändern wird in
Deutschland die umstrittene Kommunalwahl
in der DDR hat noch nicht stattgefunden
aber es brodelt im Osten in der
Sowjetunion lockert Staatsführer
Gorbatschow seit vier Jahren den Kurs
und die Bewegung solidarność in Polen
strahlt auf die anderen kommunistischen
Staaten ab immer mehr Menschen wollen
die DDR verlassen allein bis ende 1988
hatten 110.000 Bürger einen
Ausreiseantrag gestellt aber viele haben
sich auch gut eingerichtet im zweiten
deutschen Staat wie man ihn ja auch
nannte einer von diesen Leuten ist
Wolfgang Schmidt nach der zehnten Klasse
macht er eine Lehre zum Kranfahrer im
Stahlwerk Brandenburg anschließend
wechselt er zu Bereitschaftspolizei es
gerade mal 19 Jahre alt erfolgreich und
sagt über sich selbst dass er sucht und
Ordnung mag die Arbeit bei den
Sicherheitsorganen gefällt ihm so gut
dass er Karriere macht er bringt es bis
zum hauptwachtmeister in dieser Zeit
lernte auch seine erste Freundin kennen
Christine ist 15 und damit vier Jahre
jünger als er bis zum ersten Kuss dauert
es viele Monate bis zum ersten Sex fast
zwei Jahre im April
1989 gerät sein Leben aus den Fugen
zusammen mit ja Gleichgesinnten klingt
jetzt ein bisschen harmlos
Kumpanen feiert er in der Kaserne Adolf
Hitlers 100 Geburtstag es wird
fürchterlich gesoffen der skandalöse
Abend dieses Besäufnis zieht ganz
schnell Kreise und Wolfgang Schmidt wird
entlassen seine Verherrlichung der
Nazizeit und seine
Ausländerfeindlichkeit treten offen zu
Tage
Schmidt trinkt zu viel und prügelt sich
oft und seine sexuellen Perversionen
werden offenbar unerträglich denn
Schmidt sucht schon seit seiner Kindheit
seine Rolle zwischen den Geschlechtern
wie es später im prozesseisen wird
durchwühlt der kleine Wolfgang mit sechs
die Unterwäsche der Mutter die gilt aber
als kalt und herrisch also ob es um die
Unterwäsche geht oder ob er bei der
Masturbation erwischt wird für Wolfgang
langtes Schläge im Laufe des Jahres 1989
brechen bei ihm dann alle Dämme ja und
jetzt beginnt eine Serie von morgen und
gewaltex essen die die Bild-Zeitung
später so rekonstruiert
Verkäuferin mit Gartenhacke erschlagen
24 Oktober 1989 die Verkäuferin
Edeltraud Nixdorf 50 Jahre alt arbeitet
im Garten ihres Bungalows in dez als der
Mörder bei ihr Damenwäsche klauen will
doch sie überrascht ihn da nimmt der
Täter ihr die Gartenhacke ab und tötet
sie der Ehemann verkraftet den Tod
seiner Edeltraut nicht tötet sich selbst
später mit Pflanzengift Damenwäsche auf
der Müllkippe gesucht 24 mai 1990 an
einer Mücke bei Ferch haust Christa
Naujoks 55 in einem alten Bauwagen
plötzlich überrascht sie den Täter als
er auf der Halde nach gebrauchter
Damenwäsche sucht ihr sicherer Tod
Wolfgang Schmidt gesteht später ich
packte mir ein Kabel erdrosselte die
Frau ich zog sie aus zog mir ihre
Unterwäsche an und verging mich an der
Toten er verging sich an einer Leiche 13
märz 1991 in F 34 blond einen Meter 70
groß kräftige Figur streitet sich nach
dem Frühstück mit ihrem Mann Horst die
Köchin und der Schlosser sind seit der
Wende arbeitslos sie haben ein Haus in
Neuendorf gekauft die Schulden drücken
der Ehemann damals
wütend zog sie ihren Anorak an auf die
Tür zu ich dachte nun geht sie spazieren
das beruhigt er sah seine enge nie mehr
lebend wieder die junge Frau besucht
eine Freundin auf dem Rückweg lauert ihr
Wolfgang Schmidt auf neben dem fünf
Meter breiten Sandweg hat er sich eine
kleine Höhle eingerichtet mit
zerrissenen Pornoheften und getragener
Damenwäsche als Inge Fischer die Stelle
passiert stürzt sich der Psyche Mörder
auf sie er wirkt sie sticht mit dem
Messer auf sie ein reißt ihr die Kleider
vom Leib und vergeht sich an der Toten
erst 10 Tage später wird die Leiche
gefunden in Damenwäsche die ihr nicht
gehört
Mordwaffe Büstenhalter 22 März 1991
Tamara Petrova 34
zierlich dunkelhaarig einen Meter 60
groß geht mit ihrem 3 Monate alten Sohn
Stanislav im Wald von Beelitz spazieren
ihr Mann arbeitet als Chefarzt im streng
bewachten Lazarett der sowjetami später
kann sich niemand erklären warum die
Russin in den dunklen Forst gegangen ist
sie hat das nie gemacht plötzlich
springt der Mann auf den Weg
stranguliert die Arzt Frau mit einem
Büstenhalter bis sie erstickt dann tötet
er ihrem Sohn aus dem tatort-protokoll
von damals der Täter hat das Kind mit
großer Gewalt gegen eine Baumwurzel
geschlagen die Leiche der Frau schleppt
der Mörder zu einem Haufen Damenwäsche
darunter ein rosa Rock der dem
Psychopathen den Namen rosa Riesa
einbrachte am nächsten Morgen gegen 9
Uhr finden russische Soldaten Mutter und
Kind nur 500 m von ihrem Wohnhaus
entfernt für die Polizei ist jetzt klar
hier ist ein Serienmörder am Werk zwei
Kinder können entkommen fünfter april
1991 die damals zwölfjährigen
Freundinnen Jana h und Jana W spielen am
sputendorfer Waldrand fangen
der Täter lauert auf einem Hochsitz die
Messer griffbereit der Mörder trägt
einen lilafarbenen Jogginganzug darüber
eine Küchenschürze er stürzt sich auf
seine jungen Opfer aus dem
Polizeiprotokoll ohne ein Wort zu sagen
Start der Täter auf die Mädchen ein doch
die wehren sich verzweifelt zerkratzen
ihren Peiniger des Gesicht damit hat er
nicht gerechnet irritiert lässt er von
ihnen ab flüchtet mit Kratzspuren im
Gesicht die ihn später zum Verhängnis
werden die Hautreste unter den
Fingernägeln eines Mädchens helfen
später den Mann zu überführen und die
Mädchen können wertvolle Beschreibungen
liefern um ein Phantombild zu erstellen
nicht weit vom Tatort finden Ermittler
das Versteck mit Pornoheften und
Damenwäsche er klaut Schlüpfer kein
Bargeld 6 April 1991 in Fichtenwalde hat
Talita Bremer 66 starke Medikamente
gegen ihren hohen Blutdruck genommen
schläft deshalb tief und fest die
bellenden Hunde hört sie nicht als der
Mörder in ihr Haus einsteigt der
Serienkiller erwirkt die Rentnerin
Kompression der Halsweichteile heißt es
bei der Obduktion
vergeht sich an ihrer Leiche bevor er
das Haus der Witwe verlässt klaut er
Blusen Röcke und Schlüpfer seines Opfers
3000 Mark Bargeld lässt er liegen
Joker überwältigen den rosa Riesen 1
August 1991 der Mörder zieht wieder los
unter der Grünen Tarnjacke trägt er
einen hellblauen Unterrock und einen BH
mit einem Fernglas will er nach Opfern
Ausschau halten doch erregt Verdacht bei
den Joggern Mike klein und Andreas
Siegel denn er masturbiert während der
durchs Fernglas guckt was machst du hier
fragen die Männer
ich gucke nach Enden sagt der Mann sie
packen ihn entdecken die Frauenkleidung
und ein Brecheisen unter der Jacke sein
Appell lasst mich laufen ich bin schwul
ich kriege nur Ärger mit der Polizei
aber die Jogger überwältigen den Mann
und liefern ihn bei der Polizei ab in
der folgenden Nacht gesteht Wolfgang
Schmidt ich habe sechs Menschen
umgebracht was für eine unfassbare
schreckliche Serie gerade wenn man sich
diese Timeline da aus der Bild-Zeitung
noch mal noch mal so durchliest wie wir
das jetzt vorgetragen haben ehrlich so
viel Gewalt Perversion so viele Opfer
die Menschen im Süden Berlins lebten
Monate lang an Angst der Serienmörder
wurde bekannt als die Bestie von Beelitz
oder wegen seiner Körpergröße von über
1,90 m und der pinken Frauen Unterwäsche
als rosa Riese
die Polizei warnte Frauen und Mädchen
davor allein im Wald spazieren zu gehen
Bürger wären bildeten sich aber am
ersten August 1991 haben es eben gehört
hat der anderthalb Jahre dauernde
Schrecken endlich ein Ende Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft können den Prozess
gegen Wolfgang Schmidt Vorbereiten der
beginnt am 20 oktober des selben Jahres
vor der ersten strafkammer des
Bezirksgerichts Potsdam die Anklage
lautet auf fünfachen Mord zwei versuchte
Morde einmal Totschlag sowie zweimal
versuchten Totschlag und es ist Richter
Hans Walter Ehrenstein der im Licht der
Öffentlichkeit steht im Zeugenstand sind
Angehörige und Opfer wie Edith Weber die
ja zum Glück davon gekommen ist
besonderes Gewicht hat bei diesem Fall
die Einschätzung der psychologischen
Gutachter im Prozess gegen den rosa
Riesen sind dies ein Professor Dr
Wilfried rasch und Diplom-Psychologin dr
Renate Vollbad sie beurteilen schm als
durchschnittlich intelligent bei Tests
wurde außerdem ich zitiere jetzt ein
hohes Maß an depressiven Gefühlen wie
Einsamkeit und Minderwertigkeit
festgestellt rasch attestiert das
Schnitt eine kranke sexuelle Entwicklung
durchlaufen hat und dadurch unter
anderem sadistisch und auf Fetische
fixiert geworden sein in der zweiten
Novemberhälfte ist Zeit für die
Plädoyers die Staatsanwaltschaft fordert
15 Jahre Haft und die Einweisung in ein
psychiatrisches Krankenhaus die
Verteidigung plädiert eine Woche später
auf Freispruch wegen Schuldunfähigkeit
und Unterbringung in einer
psychiatrischen Klinik
Richter Ehrenstein verkündet das Urteil
am 30 November 15 Jahre Haft zuvor
Einweisung in ein psychiatrisches
Krankenhaus für sechs Morde und zwei
Mordversuche die Tötung des Babys wird
als vorsätzlicher Mord gewertet der
Überfall auf die beiden Schülerinnen als
ein Mordversuch zusammen erfasst nach
dem Prozess wird Schmidt in der
geschlossenen Abteilung des Hauses 23
der psychiatrischen Landesklinik
Brandenburg untergebracht das Gelände
grenzt zu einer Seite an die
Justizvollzugsanstalt auf der anderen
liegt der gorddensee mit einer
Badestelle und jetzt könnte es
eigentlich ruhig werden um den rosa
Riesen aber das tut es nicht seit 1994
lebt Wolfgang Schmidt als Frau und
möchte Beate genannt werden das wurde im
Jahr 2001 auch gerichtlich anerkannt
Schlagzeilen macht der rosariese aber
vor allem durch die Entscheidung der
Justiz über Lockerungen schon 1994 also
im dritten Jahr nach dem schulspruch er
hält Schmidt lockerungsstufe 3 und hat
einmal im Monat im Begleitung von
Pflegern
dabei geht mit unter anderem im Bikini
in einer Tankstelle Einkaufen die
Lockerung wird wieder kassiert und 2010
wenn man das Bildarchiv untersucht das
nimmt also kein Ende 2010 gibt es sogar
noch mal einen Prozess gegen Schmidt ich
sage ab jetzt mal Sie also Beate Schmidt
soll eine Mitgefangenen vergewaltigt
haben die übrigens ebenfalls früher ein
Mann war aber das Verfahren wird
schließlich eingestellt das vorläufig
letzte Mal macht Schmidt 2013
Schlagzeilen seitdem darf Beate und der
Aufsicht auf dem freien Teil des
Klinikgeländes spazieren gehen also
lieber Mücke wenn man sich all diese
Zeitungsartikel und Protokolle für
diesen Fall anguckt der war auch in der
Presse immer sehr umstritten der Fall
Bild als Boulevardzeitung immer mit
klarer Kante Bild hat harte Strafen
gefordert Bild war gegen haftlockerung
und der Spiegel z.B dagegen der hat Bild
hat kritisiert und uns vorgeworfen Bild
habe Schmidt schon vor dem Urteil medial
hingerichtet und ist auch völlig nicht
ganz einfach sich hier zu positionieren
oder wie siehst Du das weißt Du Stefan
ich finde das gar nicht so kompliziert
denn hier ist ja als Täter eindeutig
identifiziert worden von daher kann es
eigentlich ja nur ein klares Urteil
geben ja ich gebe Dir recht also wir
haben da kommen wir auch gleich zu diese
diese Kontroverse auch noch mal in den
in den Shownotes ich glaube zumindest
wenn es den Fall heute gebe dann würde
der noch kontroverser diskutiert bei
diesem Stichwort Transgender und die
Geschlechterrollen weil darüber ja auch
in Social Media gerade mit mit
ungeheurer Wucht gestritten wird ja das
ist richtig und natürlich aber ich
glaube das ist ja keine Entschuldigung
für die Taten die ergangen hat denn
nicht jede Person die sich im eigenen
Körper fremd fühlt und dem anderen
Geschlecht zugehörig reagiert darauf ja
mit Gewalttaten ganz im Gegenteil diese
Leute sind am meistens große Probleme in
der Gesellschaft und anerkannt zu werden
und von daher
würde ich das wäre das für mich auf
jeden Fall keine Entschuldigung für das
was er getan hat ja also sicherlich hat
er psychische Probleme und auch da kommt
man wie immer zu dem Punkt dass man das
natürlich behandeln muss dass man solche
Leuten
mit Hilfe zu teil werden lassen muss
aber das rechtfertigt definitiv nicht
seine Taten auf gar keinen Fall damit du
auf jeden Fall und das skurrile ist aber
bei diesem Feier dass der Typ
ursprünglich sagen wir mal als als Nazi
als Neonazi in seine kranke Karriere
gestartet eine Ideologie die das
eigentlich strikt abgelehnt hat das
macht den Fall aus meiner Sicht zu
besonders absurd aber die Opfer des rosa
Riesen bringt das alles natürlich nicht
zurück und deshalb hat das letzte Wort
dazu mit selbst sie sagt 2010 in einem
Interview mit Bild lasst mich nie wieder
raus das habe ich nicht verdient
[Musik]
den Fall des rosa Riesen haben wir mit
Artikeln von Bild und Bild am Sonntag
und aus der Welt erzählt dazu gibt es
einige Links in den Show Notes und dazu
stellen wir auch den Spiegel Artikel aus
dem Jahr 92 von Gerhard Mauz mit der
Kritik an der Berichterstattung der Bild
das Glück für diesen Fall hat uns Stefan
vorbereitet Aufnahmen und Schnitt wie
immer durch die fabelhafte Toni Heier
Postproduktion weight watch Studios
München wir hören uns und euer Stefan